you
[Music]
fight the [ __ ] power [ __ ]
August [ __ ] dirty and dirty first the
last day of the [ __ ] mudslinging dick
and giving our bubblegum this is what it
works you understand me
you don't want to go out with Chris
Brown putting the come to some broads
[ __ ] neck for no [ __ ] reason uncle
Joey here brightening you your day with
beautiful good news I wasn't gonna do a
[ __ ] thing this morning but I'll show
you people something and I show you the
weed without a bit and we come by going
everywhere we get sweet from captain are
you but you're not getting this let me
show you this [ __ ] this is house fire
there's from my man Manny he grows this
[Music]
the [ __ ] quarterback would stand up
for this you put this in this [ __ ]
[ __ ] and look at this badge here
look if you don't people don't love this
this is the [ __ ] gorilla glue this is
when the gorillas they shot and [ __ ]
fly Elizabeth came out of his [ __ ]
first check this out check this
[ __ ]
goodness oh my goodness look at that
that's the way to start the morning most
of you [ __ ] jerk-offs and making a
cow ate whatever that [ __ ] green [ __ ]
is I think through big feet you know I
gotta gets rich as the [ __ ] front me
you understand
nobody's doing dick and look we still
got from yesterday
oh the Sabo G and the [ __ ] cents a cup
guys need to come to show up like a
[ __ ] half a [ __ ] I'm showing up a B
two dicks one coming out my ass and one
in front of me understand me so if you
bump into me from here direction you're
getting big I love this bar this tag I
judge it to today I got a meeting I
don't know about the podcast cause it's
[ __ ] their condition is down in the
[ __ ] studio but never fear Uncle Joe
easy I'm not gonna let you get in that
car with the [ __ ] family when I'm
getting a year for the [ __ ] Drive you
understand
look at that huh it's time for a [ __ ]
Philip you know why did you [ __ ]
hey you made it out you're doing your
dang let's try this sensei just to see
the [ __ ] job load it was the last time
you've seen whole [ __ ] Diablo on this
custom you don't you don't want to get
out of your comfort zone huh well my
friend says ten milligrams is all I need
your friends a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
don't know dick he's walking around with
a goatee and a [ __ ] fedora thinking
like he's making waves you ain't doing
thick he ain't doing thick okay mr.
Whittaker this is the way to do this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] tremendous smoking weed
with my family in the morning
Thank You snow [ __ ] your [ __ ] uncle
cuz ya'll smoking with uncle cops up
great night economy last night at the
Dark Horse up and receded my man James
showed up [ __ ] birth crisis showed up
lead every Tuesday we're up at the
[ __ ] thing don't push it
you go up there you hang out with us
that's it you say hello you have a
[ __ ] I think I'm muscles with Theresa
want it who's gonna [ __ ] stop people
I just bought [ __ ] muscle fart this
morning it was tremendous I don't even
know what that [ __ ] holder was
sometimes not even mussels with garlic
just to get this thumbing kid used out
of your [ __ ] kidneys and you liver
I love this [ __ ] I love this more than
anything [ __ ] cocaine [ __ ] heroin [ __ ]
your [ __ ] mushrooms [ __ ] all that
nonsense this is all you need to get
your day going and get your joints torn
up and let's music sound [ __ ] better
I understand
oh they got me doing this [ __ ] trust me
I'm done I don't do dick I did have a
[ __ ] billion at the Roxy of [ __ ]
miles IPOs and grapefruit oh my god
that took game of the anxiety I can't
drink I'm [ __ ] old [ __ ] I can't
drink
this is my [ __ ] nectar so we
did one of the sandstrom knowledge to a
[ __ ] sound old Jeep this hybrid is
[ __ ] strong though it's as strong as
the people with a tape of [ __ ] him
that kind of pushes you right out the
window you have some in the wind on your
[ __ ] with them this will push it right
out the [ __ ] window I like weed that
pushes you on window then you get people
yelling and people getting stabbed and
crying I love that type of week that's
the good way that [ __ ] you're smoking
huh it's so soft on my throat no [ __ ]
sector I need this [ __ ] on the [ __ ]
Wednesday Wednesday isn't made for
[ __ ] killers you understand me
Wednesday's the day you get up people
already and I can't wait to see what
kind of music the karaoke man has oh
[ __ ] is so that's this weekend I'm
talking about the day [ __ ] today is the
day that's right in front of your
[ __ ] eyeballs the rest of these
[ __ ] are worried about fried
chicken potato salad you're coming off
the jump like DMC and 84 you understand
me you don't give a [ __ ] that's what
that means you're like nah you're like
the Arab in the night you don't give a
[ __ ] no that ship sailed [ __ ] who gives
a [ __ ] what they think of him today it's
you you got your [ __ ] across the bed
[ __ ]
they're gonna pick something bad I think
I felt I came on the John I've been
robbing people for 10 years I was a real
piece of [ __ ] I didn't give a [ __ ] I'm
worried at onward you do mistakes and
you move up and forward it there's
chicks out there that suck 20 days I
think they feel my train every [ __ ]
Church talking to the priest
you know this brain but not on their
[ __ ] breath people make mistakes that
day I'm [ __ ] stone I'm hearing Barbra
Streisand music again that's not good
people
look at that look that's freshness
Walter the perennial gum Joey Sonia Tom
you want to match other [ __ ] butt
Sal oh gee in the guy Branum
muchas muchas the domino just coz I
don't know what that means but who gives
a [ __ ] at this terribly sign always
paying attention you just look at people
shake your head really really we get up
[Music]
very nice
very nice I think leave what the
technical fitness class over that Berto
cranes I haven't hurt his little
kettlebell school clothes leave the
[ __ ] sack don't ever go there's two
[ __ ] of my life three
[ __ ] of my life Tommy's that
I'm confused about it you thought would
ever find yourself he was in a van
yesterday during the for 20 [ __ ]
sweating profusely I mean that guy's a
soldier
and if I gotta get out of here got [ __ ]
for doing people to see if I got more
week to smoke I'm at the ice house
tonight but it's not me sold that Friday
I'm there with Willy bus and that the I
sighs I'm just pulling 20 sad them at
the con least we'll sundown at the
Comedy Store next Thursday on the
flappers next Friday I'm at The Improv
II they want to show and sad them at The
Improv either quite a show dog I'm
trying to make this special I want you
guys to be proud of that one you guys to
be able to show this to your friends and
listen this [ __ ] is my dog dude
I am sometimes maybe you don't have no
motivation I use you guys as motivation
I don't embarrass you [ __ ] guys so
what embarrass maybe you [ __ ] have a
good day be the best that you could
become another suck it dick is at the
end that listen when you're laying in
that [ __ ] casket way they'll be
thinking about nice people there's a
[ __ ] that they lick in that sack tonight
that's what you don't be thinking about
have a great day keep guys organized
this is everywhere I'm gonna shut up
look at the cameras on you and I'll talk
to you [ __ ] now let you know
about the podcast whatever not will do
it tomorrow night late night so you got
something from Labor Day the [ __ ]
commute you understand me I love you
[ __ ]
stay black boy I hate to think about my
pillar beating up okay it moves out and
that's it
I'll talk to you [ __ ] later
have a great day